for me adventure this way of life I
don't understand my life
we stop without adventure you need to
have a very clear what do you want to do
it and how's your your objective and how
is your braveness and my rim is to take
a summit in one it has a meter peak so
all is in the training but also the most
important is fear every 8,000 meter
Peaks is nice for me no because or every
of us it's in a different moment in my
life so everything is special in the
moment and it turns out that you
actually won the prize
I'm happy you know it I am both I'm very
happy and I never thought in my life did
one I never thought that one day I
decided to finish all this how to meet a
big and one day I and I was their
adventure of the year and it's a nice
person and I would like to tell
everybody thank you very much